[Applause]
Peyton's back in he picked up two quick
fouls Reeves behind the back draws the
back
Mr Curry allowed me to have this dance
Austin Powers the crossover behind the
back takes the contact gets the hoop and
going to the line for the possible
three-point play
what a season it's been for Reeves his
second year oh against Clay against
Steph Curry
[Music]
Thompson catches fires Airborne even
chunzel blocked by Davis
final seconds Reeves it'll kind of it
goes
the desperation launch
the NBA's best shot blocker
and then Reeves
three of us 13 points here in the first
half a dramatic end
to the second quarter in the Lakers back
up by 10.
let's go to Lisa